we only have 30,000 days on this earth
and I just made me think about you know
what do you can do when you're here how
do you want to live when you're here so
Ken and I started turning off all
screens from Friday night to Saturday
night ten years ago and we called it our
Tucker BOTS and I should tell you we are
Jewish any Jews in the house a couple
good nice representing we're not
religious Jews but we love the rituals
and we love this ritual of Shabbat but
we used to just maybe do a Friday night
dinner and that was it but really what
Shabbat is about if you're really
religious Jew is a full day of rest and
if you are a religious Jew you do not
drive you do not use electricity you
don't use money you don't do anything
that's work-related for a full 24 hours
actually they say 25 hours now what's
really interesting is that every
different culture had a day of rest as a
value it was different days of the week
it's called the Sabbath Shabbat but
every different culture had one but
really only the most observant people do
it now
and my favorite Jewish philosopher
Heschel called it a palace in time and I
love this idea that it's one day that
remember wouldn't on Sundays when all
the stores used to be closed and it the
day felt different right and now we
don't really have that as much anymore I
like to think that Buddha he was in a
state of Shabbat just all the time
because he was totally present always
and I love that this is a thousands talk
about long term thinking and the long
now this is a thousands of year old idea
and there's some serious wisdom in a
full day of rest it has been around a
long time I mean it is the fourth
commandment it is above do not murder is
take a complete day off of work and what
does work mean in the 21st century the
screens the screens are such a
combination of absolutely everything
they are of course leisure and
connecting but when you have to
photograph and filter and caption your
leisure that's work too so we never get
a moment off
[Music]